90 der städte in china sind versorgt ein
13-jähriger revolutioniert eine ganze
branche und wissenschaftler bauen ein
gigantisches teleskop diese und noch
weitere themen gibt es jetzt in den
klicks und top teams
90 der chinesischen großstädte sind
versorgt die umweltorganisation
greenpeace rief die chinesische
regierung energisch auf nun endlich zu
handeln denn in 90 der 190 großstädte in
china liegt die feinstaubbelastung in
der luft über den grenzwerten die sich
die regierung selber gesetzt hat man
dürfe die gesundheitsgefahren die vom
feinstaub ausgehen nicht außer acht
lassen
als am 15 januar diesen jahres die
feinstaubbelastung ihren historischen
höhepunkt erreichte wurde die
bevölkerung pekings dazu aufgerufen
atemschutzmasken zu tragen
junge und alte menschen sollten am
besten gar nicht erst vor die tür gehen
zu hoch seien die gesundheitlichen
risiken nur in 18 von 190 städten in
china ist die belastung unter 35
mikrogramm feinstaub pro kubikmeter
die weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
waren schon vor einer belastung bei mehr
als 25 mikrogramm
schon seit jahren ist die
feinstaubbelastung in ostasien ein
riesiges problem
vor allem im winter ist die qualität der
luft oft sehr schlecht
ursachen dafür sind die vielen
kohlekraftwerke industrieanlagen und der
immer stärker zunehmende autoverkehr
mehr infos zu diesem thema findet ihr
natürlich wie immer unten in der video
beschreibung gigantisches teleskop
geplant astronomen und wissenschaftler
aus über zehn verschiedenen nationen
wollen zusammen das größte radioteleskop
der welt bauen
das squaire kilometer array kurz sk wird
voraussichtlich über 65 milliarden euro
kosten
es sollen uns einblicke in die
vergangenheit unseres universums bieten
ab 2016 werden in australien und
südafrika
mehr als 3000 15 meter große
parabolantennen aufgestellt und alle
werden zusammengeschaltet um menschliche
störungen zu vermeiden werden die rays
mitten in der wüste gebaut
unter anderem wollen die forscher einen
riesigen 3d weltraum applus erstellen
damit könnte man besser verstehen wie
unser universum aufgebaut ist außerdem
soll albert einsteins
relativitätstheorie überprüft werden und
man ist wie immer auf der suche nach der
dunklen materie die unser universum
immer weiter auseinander treibt
ein 13-jähriger entwickelt linden
drucker aus lego der kalifornische junge
schuppan bahn ag hat aus einem lego
mindstorms baukasten einen fähigen
drucker für blinde menschen gebaut
nachdem er über die preise für übliche
trail drucker im internet schockiert war
arbeitete er an einem eigenen drucker
aus lego seinem modell kam unglaublich
gut an
es hagelte wissenschafts und jugend
preise für ihn und auch die blinden
gemeinschaft spendete beifall
denn sein prototyp kostete gerade einmal
die 350 euro für den lego baukasten
während marktübliche drucker erst bei
1700 euro anfangen und bis zu neun
kilogramm schwer werden können
ich habe mir gedacht dass man einen
solchen preis einfach nicht verlangen
sollte sagte schubert
es gibt eine viel bessere methode um das
hinzubekommen die familie gründete im
letzten jahr sogar ein kleines startup
unternehmen um den blinden druck hat zu
vermarkten
das konzept kam so gut an dass sogar der
it riese intel eine unbekannte menge
geld in das startup investierte wie
wahrscheinlich sind los vor einigen
jahren hat die air force die luftwaffe
der usa 130 tausend seiten dokumentation
über angebliche ufo-sichtungen
veröffentlicht nun hat einen blogger
nach jahrelangem studieren dieser
dokumente seine ergebnisse präsentiert
die allermeisten dieser sichtungen
zwischen 1947 und 1969 lassen sich durch
wetterphänomene erklären
die bürger sehen oft reflektion und von
sonnenlicht im nebel oder in seen fotos
geschossen werden und auf den angeblich
ufos zu sehen sein sollen haben oft
einen fehler im film in der kamera doch
über 700 der 12.000 fälle lassen sich
wissenschaftlich noch immer nicht
erklären da aber die air force die
existenz von ufos generell dementiert
kommt der blogger nur zu einem letzten
schluss zitat da ist eine vertuschung im
gange wer von euch selber mal in den 130
tausend seiten der air force stöbern
möchte findet unten in der video
beschreibung natürlich den link dazu
die mission rosetta könnte verlängert
werden nachdem die landeeinheit philae
am 12 november letzten jahres
erfolgreich auf einem planeten gelandet
ist hat man ein problem
schon nach kurzer zeit waren die
batterien leer und aufgrund der geringen
sonneneinstrahlung konnten sich die
batterien auch nicht wieder aufladen
viel ist seitdem im standby modus doch
nun hat die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa angekündigt die
mission rosetta zu verlängern
mit einer geringeren distanz zur sonne
können sich die batterien schneller
wieder aufladen und die landeeinheit
könnte die untersuchung des kometen
endlich fortsetzen
für die verlängerung der mission hoffte
esa nun auf weitere budgets klicks und
war am 12 november live band kölner
zentrum der dlr dabei und hat die
landung beobachtet zu diesem spannenden
video kommt ihr hier oben kann ich euch
auf jeden fall nur empfehlen klick da
mal drauf ansonsten findet ihr unten in
der video beschreibung alle links und
alle themen die ich gerade noch mal
angesprochen habe im detail zu rap und
zum blog geht's wie immer hier unten und
ansonsten bin ich gespannt was ist eure
meinung glaubt ihr dass wirklich mal
ufos hier auf der erde geflogen sein
könnten schreibt wie immer in die
kommentare wir diskutieren gerne mit
euch und ansonsten sage ich vielen dank
fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal